when we first got introduced to function
composition we looked at of actually
evaluating functions at a point or
compositions of functions at a point
what i want to do in this video is come
up with expressions that define a
function composition so for example i
want to figure out
what is f of
g of x
f of
g
of
x and i encourage you to pause the video
and try to think about it on your own
well g of x in this case is the input to
f of x so wherever we see the x in this
definition that's the input so we're
going to replace the input with g of x
we're going to replace the x with g of x
so f of g of x is going to be equal to
the square root
of instead of an x we would write a g of
x
g of x
g of x squared
g of x squared minus 1. now what is g of
x equal to well g of x is this thing
right over here so this is going to be
equal to the square root of
g of x is
x
over
1 plus x
we're going to square that
we're going to square that
minus 1.
so f of g of x is also a function of x
so f of g of x is the square root of and
we could you know write this as x
squared over 1 plus x squared but we
could just leave it like this it's equal
to the square root of this whole thing x
over 1 plus x squared minus 1.
now let's go the other way around
what is g
of f of x
what is g of f of x and once again i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it on your own
well
f of x is now the input into g of x so
everywhere where we see the x here we'll
replace it with f of x
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
f of x
over let me do it in the same color so
you can appreciate it better
f of x over
1 plus f of x
1 plus f of x and what's that equal to
well f of x is equal to the square root
of x squared minus 1 x squared minus 1.
so it's going to be that
over
1 plus
the square root
1 plus the square root
of x squared minus 1. so this is the
composition f of g of x you get this
thing this is g of f of x you get this
thing and to be clear these are very
different expressions so typically what
the composition one way isn't going to
be the same as the composition the other
way unless the functions are designed in
a fairly special way